[Music]
and Robo patrol news it's not the same
without david cuz he's the one that
started it oh if only david was here
would make sense yeah I got you
submitted by somebody dial nine-one-one
somebody caught up on Easter yeah okay
I've done all that song shooting star
robots are being used to deter homeless
people from setting up camp in San
Francisco what are you doing bringing
them down or something
they have like blowtorch drones and [ __ ]
like they come up and just burn their
[ __ ] tents yeah they turn you should
like the [ __ ] cutest little robot
please please sir what is it like a
little wall-e
excuse me can you please evacuate put
him across the street oh boy
so the SPCA with aka the Society for the
Prevention of Cruelty to Animals
the dog was homeless people are animals
to them oh that's Cruelty to Animals
right what the hell so the San Francisco
branch they hired a k5 or canine I've
seen I've seen two different reports
robots built by this company called
nightscope to patrol the sidewalks
outside of its facilities because
they're saying that there were a lot of
encampments happening around the
facilities where the employees didn't
feel safe the SSCP ASPCA I see okay so
they're like it's like their own little
security guard further they're building
okay I thought this was like in the
middle of random streets in San
Francisco well it is like on the the
sidewalk of there's some facilities to
the point where it like people are
saying like that's not right
the Cruelty to Animals nonprofit
organization is [ __ ] kicking out human
beings back cat what if that homeless
guy had dogs with him Oh didn't take the
dogs and kick that human being away
they're like the dogs can stay yeah but
you homeless because they're saying that
they couldn't use the sidewalks at all
that there were needles and tents and
bikes so from a walking standpoint we
got heroin needles just all over the
floor yeah and so I'm gonna show you
guys a clip of how the robot look how
friendly I wasn't too off so it's
Wally's other friend it's kind of like a
chihuahua the mall security robot looks
like something out of 1984 dude I'm
gonna play the video like how they
thought the future would look like why
is it making future services because
it's from their futures to keep them
from sleeping what does that do it just
looks like it's supposed to be just
annoying it's just the white noise
machine on wheels if they wanted to
scare homeless people away that thing
would just be passing out job
applications thank you I'm [ __ ]
around wait so what is it it just plays
loud noise like patrols the sidewalk
right and so it has like heat sensors
and it's able to contact actual actual
authorities if they find people that
aren't supposed to be there and so the
authorities come over and then they
handle the human kind of like just a bit
like a rowboat so it's a rebel snitch I
see this kind of pisses me off a little
bit was shouldn't that money go towards
the Pens instead of the [ __ ] robot oh
they're gonna say okay well it's similar
a lot of people are saying like oh yeah
don't spend this money that we're
spending on the robot on the actual
helping the the whole new situation yeah
oh no not the homeless history oh yeah
[ __ ] them kitty cats because
business model is to take care of so yes
it doesn't make sense for them to be
like oh let's help the woman it just it
for me it's like oh my business is to
save animals why am i spending in a [ __ ]
of robots yeah what's with the it's like
okay yeah it looks pretty good you know
what it needs it needs a chihuahua decal
what was that about
yeah it needs a kitty cat marketing duh
this can you imagine being a homeless
guy in a sleeping bag in a [ __ ]
little chihuahua robot comes and [ __ ]
with you know it's already scared they
already see things enough yeah already
high as [ __ ] yeah now you need to be
validating your concerns that like are
you kidding me what does it do does it
spray like Mason [ __ ] let's bring
anything it doesn't it just pretty much
just tells oh they're gonna accent the
cops
yeah and that cause authority but like I
feel like if I were a cop and I got that
call from like I knew was from the
stupid robot I'll just ignore it is too
I think they're gonna accidentally start
a new religion amongst the homeless
people I would worship this robot yeah
it looks that futuristic Evan Lee music
playing while it's robot rings would you
give it oh I mean I would noodles
anything I have yeah right so it's
sprinkle rice like I'm in a Bali Street
they build a crayon out of used needles
yeah this thing has lasers cameras since
laser force and they don't specify why
lasers but I could point at [ __ ]
accurately duh yeah [ __ ] blind the
homeless man okay so I'm just imagining
someone from the SBC went to an engineer
and said listen I need you to build a
machine for me no this isn't the first
company that's using so other big
companies like Microsoft or uber
they've been using these robots to
patrol their parking lot so they made
homeless
anti homeless robots but it's like
there's a company out there like [ __ ]
tired of your homeless problem it's not
really for like so that's just a
security robot yeah right just layers oh
they're saying it's not really an anti
homeless robot but that is what it does
you know I mean like it's
the mini function it's one of the many
functions I like his name is Bob it's
not anti homeless robot yeah cuz they're
saying that this this robot cost less
than a security guards hourly wage oh
these robots are about seven or six
dollars an hour so they are able to just
have to have an hourly wage yeah the
company rent the rent them out I love
that what the security guard currently
does like if he's gonna see the robot
take his job he's like I guess that is
all we do they're trying to get like the
intent behind this is to give security
guards like superhuman eyes and ears so
they're able to see cuz these robots can
scan the perimeter and see if there's
any suspicious criminal activity
happening and that's when they contact
the security guard and then the security
what guard we'll go over and see what
they have to pay extra money pretty
exactly that's why people are like this
is [ __ ] well that makes sense if you
see security guards in action there's on
the phone or I listen to music
yes that's a Carradine no but that's
everywhere they're not security anything
I I got my guard card when I was like 19
and they said that basically you don't
do anything but watch you let a
scarecrow
you know you're you're you you know I
ended up not getting the job but I had
to get a guard card first and at the
time they're paying like 17 bucks an
hour I know like and I was like what do
I do
oh you just greet people and then you
know you just your eyes and ears for the
police so you're just that you're just a
page huh you said it's a course it's
just like a questionnaire and then you
kind of like it's a test and then you
after you do that you get your card have
to pay for that yeah so you pay for that
you didn't get a job but anyways that's
not the point okay I decided to declare
karts instead instead at Target it was a
better job came a card thickness yeah I
became a car technician but the point is
it's easy and the point of a security
guard is basically to be the designated
person if anything happens if the cops
come then you report to them and you say
this is what happened this is what I saw
and he trained you kind of like how to
report things clearly okay that's why
whenever I feel like sometimes I go to
like those Chinese restaurants is those
plazas
and the security guards like this five
foot zero 98 year old man you know but
he's got a gun though no he doesn't even
like he's like his belt would tip him
over so I'm just like why are you here
why would your family let you be out
here you know he's just the eyes and
ears yeah yeah he's not meant to do
anything with this robot since it has a
cameras and [ __ ] if I wanted to rob the
place when I just throw a blanket over
it well yeah they're saying that they've
seen these robots oh you could just do
that another thing that they found
robots with feces smeared on it and [ __ ]
like people are like [ __ ] your [ __ ] over
the camera did Planet of the Apes come
out of one of one of these robots the
same model going rogue now they've
previously knocked over a toddler in the
mall another one also fell into a
fountain in DC [ __ ] I would love to be
the mom of that kid it's like that damn
robot Ryan hit my kid like like like you
start to become racist against all that
I just have like money signs on my eyes
paycheck I get pissed at my child you
know what that was that's an American
statement
it's American it's an American thing it
looks like a big-ass dildo it's a bullet
look a blip yeah yeah but bullet that
met r2d2 and [ __ ] had a baby you know
I don't know half of all robots look
like garbage again
yeah and it's r2d2 colors blue in white
the Chihuahua on it yeah would you want
it to look like a human yeah I was
picturing like a buff ass human being
robot like Robocop I wanted to look yeah
I mean like with my laser eyes a scan
back and forth and [ __ ] or I want it to
be like really cute like that but then
like you press a button and then all
these [ __ ] dildos come out like in a
circle and then like it starts spinning
like crazy
the [ __ ] robot now milk cousin the
homeless men don't want to get slapped
in the face with a dildo he's like oh
[ __ ] yeah they might like it they might
like it okay yeah no you never know I
don't think they judge over there too
harshly so what are the homeless people
supposed to go then they just don't have
the rope they just go downstairs what
are you talking about oh you can go
downstairs never they could never go
downstairs everyone's bitching about all
robots gonna take over the earth I'm
making I'll just build stairs around me
fell no jumping oh yeah that's true but
those are expensive as hell I don't
think they'll be able to mass-produce
those what if they weren't being worthy
I'll just tip the robot over see maybe
I'm more blankets dude right just throw
blankets over all the robot I probably
just send an alarm to the old town hotel
and then the security guard to come over
but the security odds on our team we you
the human work and robots not survive
you guys are in the sand in the rain or
water underwater hell yeah rocks don't
rest yeah all volcanoes they can't
survive that but we can't either man
about Friday he's like in space it's
like well we were [ __ ] up there too
man yeah they probably could survive
they could actually they're like
cockroaches
[Music]
[Music]